so i heard i got all kinds of
um fan mail not fan mail but
kinds of uh fans that watch up
watch you watch here oh yeah you've got
them yeah you have people that watch
your videos on your back yeah yes yeah
fine what are we doing
okay um
we gotta get rid of all this all the
bags
everything yeah all the stuff today
thank you
okay hold on a second
what's been going on in my life
ruby you seem so like together and
intelligent well you speak the way you
are aware of things and yet you're
living on the street like a crazy person
yeah yeah
so so i have a hard time kind of coming
yeah well look at all these diamonds
i don't know i think there's stuff like
this all day long but where where were
you 10 15 years ago
at home with raising your kids yeah
living a normal life in suburbia
i was always a drug addict but the
the judge said that i could get the kids
back because he believes that i can
change
and i said whenever at the time's right
that i can change i will there's a lot
of us that believe in change
and i believe that truly because like my
children i know
they're missing me a lot but i can't
have them here with me
there's
it's crazy out there anyways i just said
do what you got to do
and now my when my dad took my babies um
out of
my mom my dad knew 1987 they were going
to start doing this
start doing what whatever's going on
whatever kind of
witchcraft i don't know what to call it
now
at this point well so and i'm not
a filthy person it's because i'm outside
and i do my job and you're working all
the time and i work yeah
you're wrong i'm in the field but look
what i come up with people
like people do this for me and
it's so amazing like i'm gonna ask for
anything more
but as i'm going through this but i miss
my family tremendously
i mean so back to your life before you
end up i
played sports in high school but but
were you i graduated six months early
before my class
you were smart i guess yeah i wasn't
very smart i was
very stupid at that time no but i can
tell you you're slow you're very
aware and intelligent okay that's
whenever i was younger
whenever i got like in my high school i
i was having problems
with reading and stuff well i taught
myself over the years
how to read faster and stuff and how to
put things together if something was
wrong you know what i'm saying
like um like through
let's say sixth grade
to but i don't remember none of my young
young young life really i don't
that's like a blur like fourth grade i
can remember my teachers i can remember
a little bit this that but i don't
remember everything
you grew up where garden grove garden
grove so suburb of l.a
orange county orange county yeah yeah um
and your childhood was good great
nothing crazy happened
yeah but it was nothing that wasn't
normal
yeah all right it wasn't adam my mom my
mom
like i was always in and out of
restaurants my dad he worked at the
restaurant my stepdad
so he met my mom whenever i was like
pregnant in her stomach
he is mexican from sinaloa he wasn't
from sydney he was yeah he was from
sinaloa
um yeah no then my dad
no he wasn't my aunt my grandmother no
my grandmother my grandmother my
grandmother and all those family they're
no they're not the ranchers out there
how i met the mexi mafia is because i'm
15 years old
i i met my my street dad
and he doesn't make skin well that's
what you're talking about yeah so my dad
he was like into bull fights my other
dad and
[ __ ] like that like real real stuff
now i don't know
but yeah i don't know how this came
i mean you started using drugs at what
age
not till i was 18. but you had kids
later on right yeah 18. so you had kids
when you were using drugs um no
i was using yeah maybe i just started
using when i got pregnant with my
daughter but i didn't
i didn't stop but i'd only use like two
times
well i was pregnant what was your drug
then a mess on that
yeah but it wasn't weed was my thing
today and what are you using today
um nothing whatever i use it doesn't
matter everybody else is out there but
you're using drugs today
um sometimes yeah yeah yeah
because i have to just to cope with all
the [ __ ] and the pain
and all kinds of stuff what kind of pain
that was downstairs talking that's right
i don't know i met god the other day
though
i don't know what to tell you about that
one but
when did things go haywire in your life
when i met my my my husband
and what kind of stuff happened um
i just been distracted by his family
since then
i didn't know his family i didn't know
nobody i didn't know any of them but a
couple just a mother and father
the father of his his his father
um yeah that's what my [ __ ] went haywire
he he just thought that he was going to
take on and
put whatever he did i don't care
whatever is real i don't know
but what i do is i do i fight for the
people
that's what i did and i fought for my
people number one
what i heard is two years ago they they
dropped him off deck
oh i don't know if that's true
i believe maybe it could have been i
don't know but i woke them all up
i woke all those to them told them get
up out of their graves and they did and
i said how'd you try to get out
did you crawl would you do they said
they dug themselves out
how the hell did they take themselves
out of a coffin i'll never know
but that gate must have that key mr
unlocked
and something must have pushed on top of
their
their coffin you know what i'm saying
and sure they
somebody had to help them about their
they got out of there
and i don't know how but they did and i
haven't and that's the kind of people
once you start talking to
is those kind of people that i've woken
up ruby
what was your best memory in your life
my grandma my grandma my my grandma
and and my mom
just our our our bonds we had together
i missed that a lot
yeah is this the worst point of your
life right now
you seem happy every time i see you you
seem like in a good mood you're cheery
i have to be because um
it could be a lot worse off like today
i've seen
i've seen so much [ __ ] in my lifetime
that i'm just grateful
where do you sleep now at my friend's
house
then in a tent outside
tent yeah
where do you get money i don't i just do
my thing
but they take good care of me where do
you eat
i eat whenever it comes it comes
out here some days you go without eating
no because they have all these places
around here
they're free yeah so i don't ever go
without
food now if i want to eat the food maybe
not yeah
i'll trust [ __ ] out there you know what
i'm saying i really don't
but but i have to trust something you
know i'm saying and i do and i trust
whatever but like yeah i have hope
i have a lot of hope
you read that one and i'll give you
another book trade i got so many of them
i don't know what to do okay this book
this is the big one this is that's a
big no you always bring me gifts yeah
but
it's worth it with you i like you a lot
whenever i didn't see you for a while i
kind of got scared
no i go out of town sometimes i do i get
i get a little
a little uneasy but then i tell them
that they have to show you to me or or
some
something of that sort so i know that
you're okay
because if not i'll find you i'll do my
best
have you you've been treated for mental
illness or
psych meds or anything like that yeah oh
yeah they threw me in the hospital but
it was my husband's boyfriend i mean my
husband's family that so we're all cops
apple valley here so they were [ __ ]
busting me left and right
you're not dead or taking him in here
try this phone tell me how you
how you like it that's brand new
i never got and i don't use phones very
often so there you go
thank you for the books yeah you again
oh sorry it's okay yeah so that's it
so you're do you do you currently take
your psych meds
nope no i don't need them i'm straight
as an ace i can get every point on point
and once they tell me that i [ __ ] up
real bad then let me know but i didn't
ever intentionally blow my friend up
over there but he came right back thank
god but still
i just turned around and i watched when
i didn't i don't remember if i dropped
something and
i don't know it some [ __ ] set off when's
the last time you saw your family
um kids or anything a long time like
three years
two years two and a half years they
probably know you're down here right
i don't know because when i went to both
of my friends my
aunt's houses in my my mom's house it
was empty
so i don't want to talk about it yeah
but we're good
but yeah i have a good life i mean with
friends like you
that i can actually trust really
honestly i know
i have met you you were um like a doctor
you were a german not you're um
you would fix like certain surgical
doctor
that's what you do face surgery and i
know that
and i know that but you were out of um
it was um
hollywood north hollywood
no no was it it was a
north hollywood yeah it was i don't
think so yeah
that's where i i have seen you before in
my in my
in my picture i don't make it up there
very often okay but you never did
surgery
never doctor i should have but i never
did never pursue it
do you have a brother that does it i got
a sister that kind of does it yeah
okay no no no
no it had to be well i know you're
somewhere up there with the doctor or
something like that
i'm just a photographer well you're
beautiful at it i love you
and i love you for every everything you
do i love you too ruby
yes sir every time i see you i smile we
do i just
i just want you to be happy and healthy
and back with your kids and all that and
i just don't know
but now i don't know it's not gonna
happen be anything possible to the world
changes
so the world changes what's what needs
to change with the world
so the world changes
the world seems to be changing a lot
right lately real bad
quick i've seen so much out there
it'd be it'd blow your mind but i stay
like i don't let that get in my way i
just tell them like
well it ain't gonna be me today and
that's all the day
he goes in and i just keep on going
along with with what with my day
and i'm like yeah i'm not an easy person
but i'm not a
rough i'm not a hard person but i've
been through hell and back
how i've lived i'll never know i'd love
to see who you were 10 15 20 years ago
you could go back and i'd love to see
you come go back there again or
i'll allow you to go back to that you
can go back and
review those records everybody else has
pretty much in schools
so you can uh that's why i like about
you is because you would
always ask you know what i'm saying
that's such a good a good thing
because i felt like everything has been
stripped from me they went all the way
back
to where i used to live in the hospital
24 hours a day all the time like never
would go i hardly go home because i had
asthma so bad
now they're calling this the asthma
thing or whatever or
cancer thing i don't know what to leave
anymore
because they've seen a lot of those
doctors that were [ __ ] in those rooms
with me
that came out here and why are they in
my life like that
i'll never know so i don't know what
year
or what age this started or when they
started doing this
but i want to say it was five years ago
but now i don't know
you know i really don't know are you
confused yeah
why do i have dogs coming down the
[ __ ] [ __ ] is
this weird [ __ ]
ghost [ __ ] where i see
like i call for an angel and he brings
god a [ __ ] football angel
i'm just like where does that come from
you know what i'm saying but i'm
grateful for it what troubles you the
most
are you afraid are you just not i have
been able to
lay still
you're all your mind's always smooth
just like
nothing in me just that ooh feeling you
know what i'm saying
that's what i miss just relaxing
and not feeling nothing in this
neighborhood that's impossible
no just like every nerve in my body
relaxed and not
something jumping jumping out i'm just
little
that's what what bothers me the most
lately but other than that i'm good
because they haven't beat me
they haven't beat nothing that hit no in
total organs they already did they
hit the brain brain's gone we already
determined my brain's gone
there's no way in hell i could have
right
so i'm one of those people there i don't
know it's just god
god didn't he knew what to do because he
told me these tankers that were so big
and i said how do you
what the hell you do i said now i've had
it i don't even want to know
turn it out walk away and they showed me
how they did it
the other day and it was pretty neat
but yeah you know um stuff like that
so they they last like stacked
weird [ __ ] i've ever seen whatever he
says i'm with him
you know but i love you
and i'll never stop um
i i thank you for having you here just
sometimes you know what i'm saying to
yourself
one little push that i do have somebody
else and
you can have two different friends you
can't
yeah who am i to say that you can't
that's not me
but just you know don't interfere in my
life i'll never interfere in yours and
you can always come and see me
i don't care but then there's some some
people that i just don't ever want to
see in my life
right here and and i'm and i mean that
and i mean that i'm gonna get that back
and when i say that it's not just me
saying that
i truly mean that because if i can't
have a life
where i can't have my street and
somebody don't come up
that knows that i don't want them there
they're not they're not welcome there
you know and that's where it has went so
far
okay ruby thank you so much for coming
in again
yes sir always lovely talking to you
we're talking to you too
yes sir can i buy you some lunch today
yes please you got it yes sir
i still see those these glimmers of the
old
yeah you can you can go in and you can